believe it or not our original idea for
what became infamous was all the way we
described it was its animal crossing but
you're a superhero and it's super
different than what we ended up shipping
as the game we like all of these social
interactions like yeah absolutely so
yeah a lot of kind of simulation stuff a
lot of interacting with the city and
really owning it as a superhero and you
know as we were working as we kept
iterating it became clear that what the
game really wanted to be was something
different than we thought it wanted to
be right so what we wanted it to be you
can't have to let it grow right because
you talked about the game absolutely you
have to think of it that way you have to
let you have to listen to what the game
is telling you you have to actually try
it but don't force it into what you
think it's gonna be right from a
mild-mannered Animal Crossing imitator
to a super-powered superhero simulator
infamous and the games that followed
have become mainstays on the PlayStation
console as well as one of the most
celebrated series in gaming now on the
eve of infamous second son's release we
take a look back at the origin story of
these electrifying action games
alongside the people who helped create
them here at Sucker Punch productions
when Sucker Punch started work on
infamous it wasn't with the intent of
making a superhero game or an open-world
game or even an action-adventure game no
no no infamous began as something much
more nebulous I think it's really true
really all the games we've made is we
really cherish that in the in the feel
of your in your hands how that game
feels it's so important that we give you
that sense of that the controller kind
of disappears there's a million details
and a lot of work that goes into trying
to make that happen the thing we spent
the most time working on was the parkour
system because we were trying to do
something that people there wasn't
something we could copy one of the
original kind of character points for
Cole was that he was into urban
exploration you know those guys who who
find old power plants or the of the
abandoned sewers or hospitals or so we
said hey look this is a kind of an
interesting thing to do we should design
a system where the player could could
parkour all over the environment what
would that be like in games typically
you think of the environment as the
backdrop
something too pretty to look at while
you're playing the game but in our games
that's not what it is it's part of the
game it's part of the gameplay you get
up close and personal with all this
stuff in the process of getting that
working right and infamous took a long
time and I think we must have written
and discarded five systems for climbing
buildings Russ always describes his job
when he's doing that is reading the
players mind through his thumbs and
getting that right it's a hard problem
and so it took a long time for us to get
to the point where we thought we were
above the bar when we don't always get
it right even now we wanted to make an
open-world game for infamous because the
nature of the move to being a super
dealer so big don't want to feel like oh
yeah I'm this demigod but I have to stay
in this tube you're gonna make a game
where you have these fantastic
superpowers you need to give people this
sandbox environment to use them in
everything was driven as how do we take
what we love about the sort of genre but
but imagine it as starting in a video
game and so the idea of if you got
powers what would you do who would be
the first person I would tell on how
would I feel about it would I go see a
doctor and then you know the more
longer-term questions of would I would
it corrupt me I think that's where the
ideas of having karma and taking an
ordinary guy giving him powers and
seeing what happens to him that was
really the genesis of that idea I
imagined it would have been easy to just
let's give him strength right speed he
can be telekinetic and like do all these
different sounds like how did you that's
exactly what sure you did like how did
you manage to stay like focus down on
one side on one particular skill thing
when we got to electricity we started
talking about it and one of the things
that we we realized was that it was kind
of the blood of a city in that when
electricity goes away the city really
struggles and when it returns it kind of
brings life to the city and so it was
interesting for him to kind of draw that
energy out of the city and when you went
into parts of town that were powered
down we thought that was actually quite
interesting and that you'd be week there
and it was kind of a natural weakness
the thing that worked for people is only
said you get to decide whether you're a
good guy or a bad guy and everyone one
don't we we'd say that in the middle of
selling tolling and like ten things and
you'd be like no way stop there right
that that was what I want you know
that's what I want from the game I want
to know whether I'm a good guy or a bad
guy you kind of ask yourself that
question if I had powers like if you
could turn invisible you know would you
use them be a nice guy or would you
sneak into the girls locker room right
video games are awesome for that because
it's a space where you can experiment
and not worry about the consequences is
it's not real but it kind of feels real
in the moment when you're playing when
the original infamous hit store shelves
back in 2009 it was welcomed with open
arms from both critics and consumers
alike in his review
GameSpot's own Tom McShea awarded the
game a prestigious score of nine
praising its ease of movement and well
paced design ultimately infamous did
well enough to warrant a sequel but a
sucker punch started planning out
infamous - they discovered everyone had
an idea for how to improve upon their
superhero formula you wanted to take
what we've done and in from the Swan
keep the good stuff and add in you know
better production values so we started
in doing mocap for the first time you
know we thought we could up the up being
any on the game play we thought we can
make it more epic more spectacular we
wanted to personify the calmness we
brought kuo and mix in the two sets I'd
carrot there's one of them kind of
embodies that ruthless approach and one
of them is more of a kind of goody
two-shoes we also tried to make a lot
better melee not for the character
because we found after and from this one
everybody wanted to knock enemies in the
face is that what you gave him the the
ampulla yeah man somehow that was
integral to the Supergirl fantasy and
it's a thing with video games you need
to ride range so that you can affect
both at a distance that's like a common
problem is that okay great this guy's
got electricity let's give him a weapon
that is pretty much a big metal pipe
that he can turn into the world's
largest taser right armed with the
largest taser in gaming infamous - was
released to the public in 2011 where it
received a positive if not a bit more
mixed reaction from consumers Tom McShea
reprised his role
our infamous reviewer and gave this game
a 7.5 praising the game's new setting
and fluid movement a taking issue with
its uneven pacing among other things for
the next infamous game Sucker Punch knew
they needed to push this series further
than they had before a new PlayStation
console is in the works and on the back
of this new technology Sucker Punch
started designing a new world a new
protagonist and a whole bunch of new
powers for infamous second son however
the one thing they want to improve upon
above all others
was infamous as karma system the term
Sucker Punch uses to describe these
branching good or evil morality choices
looking ahead from infamous 2 we kind of
look back on the data we collected on
how people were playing enormous one and
infamous 2 the data was really clear
that what people do is they decide
before they even buy the game I'm gonna
play good or I'm gonna play evil once
you decided whether you're gonna be good
or evil we didn't give you any
interesting choices so what we've done
instead was we're saying we've said ok
you're gonna be a hero you're gonna be
the good guy but how good a hero can you
be how careful are you gonna be in
combat to avoid casualties we found that
that is a much better kind of gameplay
loop you have to play that out in a
context context of combat which is a
look which is a lot harder right and so
you could play through the game and make
all the story decisions correctly but if
you're bad at they combat and you're not
keeping your gameplay aligned with that
then you're not gonna get all the way to
the kind of higher levels of good karma
and the same thing goes for evil how is
the the PlayStation 4 hardware sort of
change the way that you approach what it
is that you do you know of course a lot
of it you know of course was the upgrade
and the hardware that gave us you know
the ability to actually push this you
know big jump in cutscene quality and in
this facial animation and from from that
point of just the number of points that
they defined that surface of your
character you can get that many more
details that when you're animating you
know you see folds in the face or in the
subtle things that come through at the
start of the first infamous Sucker Punch
employed around 40 to 60 people and now
three games later that number has
roughly doubled but while sucker punch
used to grow it still tries to maintain
that tight-knit mentality of its
formative years and we found that as as
we've grown over the course of infamous
as we've gone from 50 people to 130
people that again that becomes a little
bit harder because none of us could
actually build something as cool as it
the infamous games much less second son
on our own right we all rely on each
other to make it great I mean I've been
immersed in the infamous series for six
years now right so I know intimately
exactly what's changed and what's the
same as we go from game to game but for
most people who play the game they get
moving from this game they love it then
it's another new two years before they
get to play another one we do our job
right people remember the positive
emotions they had about the infamous
games we meet their new expectations
because they want it to be better and
they think nothing's changed that's kind
of the mark of success for us as people
say well they didn't change anything
about the climbing system we did but we
just made it better in ways that you
didn't notice or that that were that
just we're better do you know that you
just were like oh that's what it's
supposed to feel like that's what I
thought it felt like last time it's
mostly because you've forgotten a ways
in which it didn't meet your
expectations